when i left vienna
i stood at distance of a few meters
and saw face to face
the ill-famed iceman e-i-c-h-m-a-n-n
the man who was responsible for the
whole holocaust
and when i then arrived
from a former camp to auschwitz
i was one one half meter distance
face to face again confronted
with another historical not to say
classical
mass murderer not only icon
but also mengele
dr mengele now you see
next dr mengele standing
there in auschwitz at the railway
station
where he stood and we had to march one
after the other
and he made such a movement right
or left see and this meant
those who were sent to the left
were immediately sent to and and to and
into the gas chambers and those who had
been ordered
to the right side which was
the minority they were
sent later on after a couple of days
into some
camps concentration camps in germany
the next picture shows you
the what remained
from the poisoning gas containers
cyclone b what the poisoning gas
that was used this picture was made in
in auschwitz in the auschwitz museum
next please this are the ovens where
the gas people had been
cremated there was not a
gas over in which people died but they
they were gassed in gas chambers
pressed about one thousand in one
sweep pressed together naked
male and female together naked and
then as i heard you may understand with
what
feeling i heard it from one of the
former prisoners who had to work
or ended up as an operator in the guest
chambers
it took the in the prisoners
13 minutes to die
13 minutes to die of course they
lost their consciousness earlier but the
the what is called in german today's
camp
struggle with struggle with this at the
duration of 13 minutes
now the next please this is a room
where we were brought into the first
the first in auschwitz it was a
disinfection room we had in
this room i believe i said it in my book
on the concentration camp
in this room we had within one or two
minutes
to be afraid of all
strip totally and and
in this room we lost everything we had
on ourselves including
any hair and so forth and i lost
in this situation the first manuscript
of the book the doctrine the soul which
i had done
the afterwards to the the luck to be
able to
reconstruct it and to rewrite it finally
the next please these are
you see wooden things on which
in three on three levels on each level
nine prisoners had to lie
it was impossible to lie on the back you
have to lie
only on one side nine prisoners
so in such an i think there was the
altogether 27 people
during the night right only to spend two
nights to be sure
the next camp in which to which i was
transported
was the camp kaufering in bavaria
and the next and last was to came also
in bavaria
let me share with you two
very small
and seemingly at first sight
unimportant experiences i had
but to me as
someone who has to do some connection
after all with logotherapy
it they have a great meaning in as much
as you might have come across some such
statements
in logotherapy in the anthropological
foundations of robot therapy that is to
say where
a logo therapy the logo therapeutic
concept of man
the question the answer to the question
what is intrinsically basically
making our making for the humanness of
any human being
we discern two things two human
capacities
the capacity of self distancing
and the capacity of self-transcending
of self-transcendence and
now i may illustrate it by two things
that happened in the concentration camps
through over the snow the the fields uh
covered with snow and bitter cold
about centigrades
below the zero uh 18 centigrades
early in the morning around about five
o'clock
we had to march about three quarters of
an hour
to the site where we had to make heavy
physical work
constructing sub terrain
supports no it's on the underground
underground
yeah and tunnels and underground uh
ammunition february bunkers
manufacturers yeah
and you may easily imagine
how tris the whole situation was and
then
i started to play a trick upon myself
by
ordering myself to imagine
i'm now standing behind a lectern
in a large lecture hall in a
warm lecture hall with in
confronted being confronted with an
interesting
and attentively listening
audience and i'm speaking about this
topic about under the title
the psychology of concentration camps
and i'm talking exactly about
the what i write at that moment was
experiencing
and thereby i put a distance between
myself
and the real situation
and i was detaching myself from the
reality the trees absolutely trust
reality
and thereby by trying
to have to adapt or embrace
a strictly scientific objective view
to this situation i put i gained
i obtained a distance to it
this was the capacity mobilizing
i was mobilizing the capacity of safe
distance
and then half a year later
i was suffering from typhus tifus
xantimaticus
in medical terms and my fee was
even higher than
40 centigrades and i knew
that there was immediate life danger
collapsing
vascular system collapsing
due to the fever and
a friend of mine another inmate of the
same camp in bavaria
stole in the office of the ss
of that camp so small
forbes and on the back on the free back
i jot it down even during night
keywords that should allow me
keywords partially by shorthand writing
keywords to enable me
later on if i survive the reconstruction
of the manuscript